when only one in three voters held their
nose and voted for a party they
considered the lesser evil in the last
general election that's according to a
new report from the electoral reform
Society
the Democrat democracy advocating group
claims December's elections all voters
marginalized on the extraordinary scale
and lays bare the crisis of legitimacy
faced by Parliament more with me as the
director of policy and research at the
electoral reform Society dr. Jess :
welcome to you so you reckon a lot of
people didn't get what they want a huge
number of people one in three people
said that they opted for a tactical vote
so they're not choosing their preferred
party or kin today and that's that's a
huge number it's up from one in five
when we asked a similar question in 2017
but it's it's not just voters it's also
parties we saw a large number of
electoral PACs this time around the
brexit party stood down half their
candidate so it's a system that's not
really working for voters there's no
point of representative democracy that
it boils down lots of people's different
preferences to a result a representative
Westminster well the first post post
system that we use in Westminster
certainly tries to manufacture a
majority but there are loads of other
systems which more accurately reflect
how voters actually voted and doesn't
force them into these awkward tactical
decisions but on the other hand that
pretty much means you never get a clear
decision whether where a lot of people
are saying they're quite relieved that
Boris Johnson has got a majority even if
they don't like him at least you can get
on with it
sure I mean there's an ATC majority on a
1.3 percentage point increase in the
vote share which many people would say
actually doesn't reflect how people
voted but you don't necessarily get that
huge majority either I mean we've seen
in the last few elections that the
system hasn't lived at that so all the
things that this system is supposed to
be good for aren't actually coming
through and we're seeing it really
warping and distorting how people vote
so where would you point to where the
system works better when we use lots of
PR systems across the UK in the welsh
national parliaments gosh the national
parliament scotland at the local level
and in northern ireland so there's lots
of different systems that we already use
in the UK
people are very familiar with which
would work really well for Missy
Scotland's an interesting case in fact
they've got a proportional system but
that ends up over representing the
Scottish National Party well certainly
Westminster system has over-represented
the SNP this time around but compare
those results to the results in the
Scottish national parliament and you see
that there's a breath of political
opinion in Scotland that isn't
represented then at Westminster there's
any chance of changing this I mean the
electoral reform society is a venerable
institution but is it actually going to
change at national level it doesn't seem
to be much enough time for it it's true
that you know if the government gets in
our large majority under one system they
tend to quite like that system but I
think even any government in power has
to look at how our current systems
really dividing the UK and the UK is
quite divided at the moment so to take
the longer view and to think about
what's best for democracy I think it's a
time to put partisan interest aside and
really think about how these results are
going to play out for the whole of the
country in the long term that would
require the support probably a volley
the labour of the Conservatives do you
think either than a movie in this
direction
it certainly seems that labour is moving
this direction we've had some good
sounds from the the candidates standing
to be the new Labour leader so we would
hope that Labour takes a look at this
and thinks that actually this could be
an area that they would they would
support and if if we did have a
proportional system what would the
government be currently it would depend
on what system and of course people
voters tend to behave differently under
different systems so when they know that
their vote can count and we've modelled
how the election might have looked on
two different systems and it varies you
certainly see more votes for the Liberal
Democrats you see slightly less with the
Conservatives and slightly less for the
SNP but it just kind of depends which
system you're using I think we'd
probably still have Prime Minister Boris
Johnson you could still have a
conservative majority certainly or you
could have a coalition government it
really depends on how things play out
and you've been doing this research to
do the public care about this
I think they care that their vote
doesn't count
whether people then move that
referendum I mean you can argue whether
that was a very good system that was
being proposed but it was you know did
pathetically badly didn't the electoral
I mean sure it was almost a decade ago
now that we had that AV referendum and
we have three general elections since
then in each of those general elections
in one way or other has shown that this
system is still creating problems for
voters and also being very
disenfranchised with politics and that's
not really a good place to be okay thank
you very much indeed voice their
electoral form Society dr. Jess Garland